what is a Spearman correlation
spearman's rank correlation examines the
relationship between two variables isn't
that exactly what the Pearson
correlation does that's right the
Spearman rank correlation is the
non-parametric counterpart of the
Pearson correlation but there is an
important difference between both
correlation coefficients Spearman
correlation does not use the raw data
but the ranks of the data let's look at
this with an example we measure the
reaction time of 8 computer players and
ask their age when we calculate a
Pearson correlation we simply take the
two variables reaction time and age and
calculate the Pearson correlation
coefficient however we now want to
calculate the Spearman rank correlation
so first we assign a rank to each person
for reaction time and age the reaction
time is already sorted by size 12 is the
smallest value so gets rank 1 15 the
second smallest so gets Rank 2 and so on
and so forth we are now doing the same
with age here we have the smallest value
there the second smallest value the
third smallest value fourth smallest and
so on and so forth let's take a look at
this in a scatter plot here we see the
raw data of age and reaction time but
now we would like to use the rankings so
we form ranks from the variables age and
reaction time
through this transformation we have now
distributed the data more evenly to
calculate spiem and correlation now we
simply calculate the P using correlation
from the ranks
so the Spearman correlation is equal to
the Pearson correlation only that the
ranks are used instead of the raw values
let's have a quick look at that in data
tab here we have the reaction time and
age and there we have the just created
ranks of the reaction time and age now
we can either calculate the spement
correlation of the reaction time and age
where we get a correlation of 0.9 or we
can calculate the Pearson correlation
from the ranks there we also get 0.9 so
exactly the same as before if you like
you can download the data set you can
find the link in the video description
if there are no rank ties we can also
use this equation to calculate the
Spearman correlation n is the number of
cases and D is the difference in ranks
between the two variables referring to
our example we get the different D's
with this one minus 1 which is 0 2 minus
three is minus one three minus two is
one and so on now we Square the
individual D's and add them all up
so the sum of d i squared is eight n
which is the number of people is also 8
in this example if you put everything in
we get a correlation coefficient of 0.9
just like the Pearson correlation
coefficient R the Spearman correlation
coefficient r s also varies between
-1 and 1 with the help of the
coefficient we can now determine two
things number one how strong the
correlation is and number two in which
direction the correlation goes the
strength of the correlation can be read
in a table if we have a coefficient
between
-1 and less than zero there is a
negative correlation thus a negative
relationship between the variables if we
have a coefficient between greater than
zero and one there is a positive
correlation that is a positive
relationship between the two variables
if the result out is zero we have no
correlation often however starting from
a sample we want to test a hypothesis
about the population we calculated the
correlation coefficient from the sample
data and now we can check if the
correlation coefficient is significantly
different from zero thus the null
hypothesis is the correlation
coefficient R is equal to zero there is
no relationship and the alternative
hypothesis is the correlation
coefficient R is n equal to zero there
is a relationship whether the
correlation coefficient is significantly
different from zero based on the sample
collected can be checked using a t-test
where R is the correlation coefficient
and N is the sample size a p-value can
then be calculated from the test
statistic T if the p-value is less than
the specified significance level which
is usually five percent then the null
hypothesis is rejected otherwise it is
not if you use data depth for the
calculation of the example we get a
p-value of
0.002 the p-value is therefore smaller
than 0.05 and we can therefore reject
the null hypothesis that in the
population the correlation coefficient
is zero thanks for watching and I hope
you enjoyed the video